mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
a rectangle measures 17 units by 26
units
seven squares are placed inside the
rectangle as shown
the question is what is the area of a
single square
a version of this problem was given to
students who were 12 to 13 years old in
vietnam
i thank ting for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
there's a clever trick that i'll admit i
didn't see
but it's a beautiful solution and i want
to share it with you
the trick is to focus on this right
triangle
suppose it has legs of a and b and a
hypotenuse equal to c
notice the hypotenuse is also equal to
the side of the square
the trick is that we can take this right
triangle
and use its lengths of a and b to
measure the vertical and horizontal
dimensions of the entire rectangle
we'll then be able to solve for a and b
and consequently we'll solve for c
so let's get started to place these
right triangles to measure the vertical
dimension of this rectangle
we will then do the same thing to place
these right triangles to measure the
horizontal dimension of this rectangle
so now let's focus on just these right
triangles
let's focus on the vertical dimension of
the rectangle which is equal to 17.
we'll focus on these right triangles
label the legs of a and b accordingly
from these dimensions we can see that
two a plus three b is equal to seventeen
we'll now focus on the horizontal
dimension of twenty-six
we'll label the legs of the right
triangles accordingly
we'll get another equation
we get that 5a plus 2b is equal to 26.
so we're now pretty much set up to solve
this problem
we're going to focus on just these
equations
we want to solve for a and b
to do that we'll eliminate the b
variable
we'll multiply the first equation by 2
which will give us 4a plus 6b is equal
to 34 and we'll multiply the second
equation by 3. this gives 15a plus 6b is
equal to 78.
we will now focus on these equations
subtracting the second equation from the
first will eliminate the b variables
we then have 11a is equal to 44 or a is
equal to 4.
from here we can substitute into this
equation and we'll get 16 plus 6b is
equal to 34 which means 6b is equal to
18 or b is equal to 3.
we can now focus on the right triangle
since it's a right triangle we have a
squared plus b squared is equal to c
squared
this leads to the equation that 4
squared plus 3 squared is equal to 25
which is equal to 5 squared so c is
equal to 5 and c squared is equal to 25.
we want to solve for the area the square
which is exactly equal to c squared this
means the area of a single square is
equal to 25 and that's the answer
what an interesting geometry
problem thanks for making us one of the
best communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you